[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh No the feed like frozen that I think
we're live down there we go we're good
hello and welcome to GameSpot's play for
all charity event this is day 9 and if
you haven't caught this before we are
raising money for black lives matters
and kovat 19 Direct Relief joining us
today is John Luke psyche hello
and Danny O'Dwyer of noclip what's up
how you guys doing I'm doing great how
are you I'm doing great I'm just
chilling here on my skateboard it's
probably hurting my back a little bit
Cobin nineteen's going on so there's no
one else in this video game can't wait
for the next two hours let's raise some
[ __ ] money like a curse I mean I don't
make the rules but yeah you can curse
thanks so much Rabb me on it's a it's
always fun to hang out with you guys I
miss you guys
all the time and I always like try and
pop into GameSpot office every couple of
months like I'll find an excuse to just
kind of come in and I can say I hate
everyone and I check in and obviously
we're not really doing that anymore at
the moment but it's been cool setting
this whole thing up in Chanti guys and
Eric Tay who's like spinning the Wheels
of Steel back there making the whole
thing going and it's fun to check in
with him especially I was like every
world like dad's and stuff like oh
that's why I'm playing skateboarding
video games cuz I feel old now I was
actually trying to do a kickflip last
weekend which I haven't tried to do in
years
and I got kind of close nice I came
Kimmo a sore I think my hip kind of hurt
and my ankles hurt but you know I was at
I was I was like my kid loves it my
daughter we go on walks and she sees
skateboarders and she loves them still
like live and fast and I have a deck
here I have my giant bomb deck up there
but I have an actual time machine over
there and when kovat had started I was
just so scared to jump on because I was
like if I twist my ankle now or like a
break a bone or sprain something I love
to go to a hospital and then wouldn't
you know it might kid yesterday we have
to like bring her to the hospital to get
a cast on her foot cuz she broke a
metatarsal not skateboarding just like
walking around so I don't know you
scared of one thing and then
something else comes free choice
ice-skating here yeah let's do it
you too you tell you tell people where
to go to donate and we'll give them
shoutouts and all that stuff right oh
yeah but the donation link for black
lives matters is bit ly / TS - BLM and
then for Coppa directive relief it's bit
ly / GS
- COBIT awesome oh dude ad for that or
something I like and I can retweet it
from the from my account as well maybe
it does sure we did all check Frankie
we'vewe've some of the noclip community
in here as well we're hosting the stream
on ours so and I see is in the chat
already probably gonna be spamming the
links and Frank our community manager is
on our Twitter at the moment so he sees
this then same thing just spam those
donation links Frank also we also have
Matt Padgett in the YouTube channel
saying I will moderate you Danny O'Dwyer
so I guess he's a making sure you don't
say anything you can't say but also Matt
if you get a chance if you can share
those links in the chat for people as
well that would be awesome
thanks John how many of these be done
now oh my god we do one a day and we're
on week two three or a week - yeah you
look like years yeah it's been
interesting it's been a lot of fun but
it's also been a lot of work I bet and
there's a lot more work to be done
yeah when you sign up for something that
you do every day the first day you're
like run out a hundred and ten percent
and then it's like 73 oh no it was
everyone I think you as well like
tweeting yesterday about like today was
supposed to be the last day e3 and
sitting here being like oh yeah in
another university of today off right
yeah I'd be like sleeping just passed
out in my bed it's wild
yeah so I'm basically like we're gonna
just shooting the breeze here today for
the for the next two hours
talking about all your donations and
stuff but also if anyone has any
questions about I don't know hi world
una t3 or or what Eddie 3 or what you
know any noclip questions I'm kind of
treating this as like this is open book
time so if anyone has any questions
about like Raven home or like anything
I'm totally ok just answering anything
for the next two hours cuz forego cause
so yeah it's like your moment sort of
arcane related I think retire a little
bit what do you think of death loop yeah
what's interesting we were just talking
about before going live is the the
trailer when table yesterday which
looked really cool but today I guess
Bethesda's blog or something put out a
Amory Lewis put out a an update that
basically explains how the multiplayer
side works and it's way crazy cuz it's
basically like the crossing that game
they tried to make in the early 2000s it
never came out which was a game where
you could invade other people's
single-player games kind of like a left
for dead when you would go into one of
the zombies somewhat like that and
that's how I guess the the female
character in death Lou who they've shown
a bunch of and Shoni you can play
you're basically evading other people's
games with her that's so yeah it's like
the coolest thing ever
yeah I like I knew you were you could
play as her in some capacity and some of
my brain I was like I hope it's it's
just what the crossing was supposed to
be and it's probably I need to know that
that's that's what that is I mean I I I
think our games one of my favorite
Studios like everything they make is
incredible like immersive Sims are just
like my jam and I I think I'm just so
excited because like I feel like this is
this is the most arcane game that arcane
has ever made where they're just taking
all their ideas and and like pooling it
into like this this super game we're
working on I'm so excited
yeah cuz you got like blink from
Dishonored was in the I'm gonna try yeah
I'm thankful Assad was in yeah like the
shooting seems a lot more almost like
there's a bit of Moon crashing into this
as well of course
nailed it yeah yeah like roguelike
elements of Moon crash which I thought
was like a really cool twist on like
immersive sim form Oh like oh man it
just you could tell yeah my gosh is like
like is one of these games it's like an
absolute sleeper hit like no yeah it's
the best it might be like archeins best
game or it's like it's one of the most
interesting games it's so tight and
compact and has such an interesting loop
and it and it's so unique like I don't
know any game that does this thing where
you have to like to complete the game
you have to basically get five different
people to escape this facility in a row
one after the other but everything you
do in the first run is like persistent
in the next run so you see you're like
you're not picking up medical supplies
so you can get them on the next run and
you're like opening a door which is
nothing to do about the run you're in
but you know it'll help you know the
other rewards later yeah it's so nobody
played it did you guys have your tryout
praised multiplayer mode that they added
because that was a pretentious on there
it was it was a little buggy when I
played but the idea of just like turning
into a coffee mug and waiting for people
was very satisfying that I wrote I feel
like I've mentioned this a million times
I'm sure okay but I'm trying doing this
trick right away is I'm trying to do a
late flip because I guess I can't I'm
kicking to light so I'm gonna try and
roll off and do a late flip but I'm not
sure if it'll let me so and but did you
ever I think I've talked to you about
this on a stream a million times days
what we heard this a thousand times
there's a quake 3 mod called crash 3
arena where you were a crazed like a
cardboard like a box Christ and all the
levels were in crate warehouses and you
do that thing you just kind of like just
in the corner pretending you're Christ
and then shoot somebody with a rocket
launcher and a round post I love stuff
like that
yeah doofy stuff
mmm bring mods back all that all the
stuff coming out of the half-life Alex
modding community now is real oh I'm
really excited for that man Wow Johnny
the game I played it to completion
actually I'd never played half-life
until a couple months before that game
came out so I went through and started
with Black Mesa I didn't actually play
one I did Black Mesa and played through
all of them and absolutely loved it
Alex and I loved Alex - I think that
might be my game of the year as of now I
know that's dumb to say cuz we're you
know there's still a lot of years left
but man I thought that game was
incredible
yeah I'm with you it's my it's my
favorite game of the earth by far I have
a very strong emotional attachment to
that series and and came in with a lot
of expectations and they somehow managed
to deliver like it's it's a super
special game I've played it twice now
and I'm playing through a black base at
the moment I'm almost complete a Black
Mesa
oh yeah it's it's really good I'm paying
to Zen at the moment which is the
obviously of the part of half-life that
is probably the people are the most
critical of because it's a bit totally
weird and weird boss fights in and
Melissa so they basically just took a
crowbar to Zen and redesign the entire
thing and it's amazing what they've done
it it's like it's demonstrably better
than the original half-life said um and
in some areas it's like it's like some
of the best gameplay in all of black
mesa but it's really cool it's a it was
it was a hard time there for half-life
fans for a good while yeah but I played
three new half-life games history like
no we're just all at once all this
half-life
it's I when I got to Xen I was expecting
because I like I said I only played
Black Mesa and I got this and I was like
alright here we go this is the part that
everyone that no one likes in this game
and actually yeah like what you're
saying it seemed really good the only
thing that felt weird was like that
whole like box factory you go through
after or whatever where you're like on
the whole you're on the conveyor belts
and I was like okay this this went on a
bit too long which was missing which
came Black Mesa like you
right oh is this in a oh an interloper
is it in - yeah that's I'm just about to
start engine over okay and I was waiting
to see when that I was waiting to see if
that thing came up because they added so
much stuff into interloper just like a
does that whole part where you're in
like a nest of behemoths yeah what are
you doing this is the same and there's
like a vorticons like yeah shoulders
turn up it's like that's wild yeah it's
so then is so long um I think uh virus
into the original it's like maybe three
or four three times longer I'd say yes
yeah I would've graphic I think that's
maybe my only real complaint is that it
maybe drags a little long
like like Jake said but I it's just so
impressive what they did with that and I
remember seeing the trailer for it back
in like 2009 summer 2010 and I'm like oh
man I'm ready for it
yeah that way that wouldn't be a half
life project if it didn't come at
incredibly late if I've learned anything
talking to like mod developers is that
like you never give a release - hey yeah
life just can get in the way in so many
different ways it's actually the size of
that thing and when people are working
on it like not full-time like it is
these days he can sort of cry it's fun
some mods and maybe get a couple of
people on it full-time but like
especially back dad knows like I need so
many people working on it like that they
had their absolutely massive team all
around the world like even just
organizing people I mean we're all
trying to figure it out now with this
covert situation right and it's like
they were trying to do that back then
before there was even tools for teams to
work remotely like that you know this is
way ahead yeah I at pax east and I was
talking to one of the devs I forget his
role exactly but he was saying how he
started on the project and then left it
for years but then like came back I'm
like that's that's blah old yeah it's so
strange if there's a whole group of
people who are like I'll be injuring at
some studio and like someone will say
like oh I saw your half left
guy was on that team I was I'm not
saying like there's just loads of people
who were like on her for a little bit
doing something yeah I just wanted to be
a part of it by the way this is session
case anyone wants to know oh my god oh
my god oh god this is a sort of a
spiritual successor
speaking of early access or you know
whatever this is a game that I guess was
announced this project session I feel
like maybe six years ago at this stage
five six years ago maybe um it's one of
two kind of skate for wannabes that are
on Steam right now the other one is
skater excel which I was gonna also play
today but it's [ __ ] out of me a
little bit it's a bit earlier in
development than this one or a good bit
earlier but the control scene on this
game is completely insane um let me show
you what it looks like so the the the
right thumbstick does the right foot
this does not play like skate it doesn't
control like skate you turn left and
right using the triggers which is wait
so you don't you don't actually turn
using the analog sticks and the right
thumbstick uses the right foot and the
left one uses the left stick so if I
want to do an ollie for instance I don't
even know how to slow down how do I slow
down oh they go okay I wonder nollie I
have to go back on the right stick and
then if I go up on the right stick you
would on skate nothing happens you go
back in the right stick and up on the
left almost as if you're you know
basically doing the movement and then if
I want to do so like Knollys are you
lean forward on the left stick or nose
manuals my nose they're the same for the
right stick so if I do shove us you ever
see have to kick your you know back foot
um front or backwards so you're a ski
like go like you like rotate to the side
like that and Ollie so I did a backside
one there so we do front side as a 360
but we that's the craziest thing about
it is if you go fakie the controls are
now reversed
this is the back foot I think it I think
they technically go back foot front foot
so now I have to go down on my left foot
and up on the right one to do yeah so
it's like and it's it's kind of feels
like it kind of feels like a Souls game
or something we're at the start you're
like how does any of this work and then
you're just in the flow and it's just
kind of like it kind of it gives me the
same chill vibes again when I play skate
three which is kind of my go-to chilla
games on my xbox one they did a really
good version of it for the Xbox one X
they like did a what do you call it like
a and hey yes yeah
and it's so good but this is this is my
other one but this one requires a little
bit more attention but it's fun and then
you can do all the same stuff to get you
in skate with you can run around in this
one you can't really yet and skater X I
don't think and then you can set
waypoints so I can get away from here
and then go back if I want so I can set
up like a I want to work on this box for
a little while here just take a go at it
and then [ __ ] it up I know that and then
go back and do it again so it's got you
are you looking forward to Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater remastered or deep because I
feel like a lot of people are kind of
over it the Tony Hawk style of
skateboarding game when there's all
these other games like this which demand
more of you they they scratch a
different it for me personally so in the
same way I could enjoy FIFA and joy like
you know sense my soccer or rocket
Leone's okay totally yeah exactly
actually that's a way better comparison
yeah FIFA and rocket League and that you
know they're they're they're they're
similar in a way they're both games I
play because I like the physics of
football and I like chilling out but but
it's a different type of thing so yeah
I'm really looking forward to it I will
if they make if they do a good version
of it I will absolutely love it and
spend loads of time in it and like any
Tony Hawk situation it's it's always you
know what teams that they are working on
it looks like Activision have stopped
giving it two teams who they're not
giving much money to and actually
investing it properly I think that's
really exciting and some of the videos
they've already had
but like a bunch of original skaters I
rented like a lesser streamer and Kareem
Campbell there had added a video at the
barracks in LA which is actually like a
stone's throw from the LA cc3 I went
there a few years ago when we're at at
e3 they did a great video where they had
like every union with the mall I think I
think Austin might have been there and
rodney mullen was there and that was
cool so it looks like they're kind of
putting putting the money and putting
the effort into it mmm Rodney Bowman it
wasn't one of credible yes like the way
he thinks about skateboarding is insane
that was that looked clean I was that
was that was really hard let's go with
that one
yeah he's like a he's like a he lives in
the stars man like I yeah he's just the
soul of skateboarding like sorry I don't
want to interrupt your conversation oh
go ahead I was just gonna mention this
two more Hussein as mentioned in the
YouTube chat we are the time earning
money for both black lives matter and Co
vid Direct Relief and you put the links
in there so please give to that in fact
we have two donations yes so I'll
appreciate it
from our very own Julio PAC $50
thank you all pac-man thank you so much
and from Matthew path you another $50 as
well so shout out to both of you
thank you purple figures already thank
you both so much Matthew path you yeah
it's amazing
I love it I call that in to his face
before I think I've just said that to
myself before dad I know but at the
chaplets Moore was asking if you
remember doing a skateboarding video
around Waterford this is I can't
remember the details um trying to
remember which one are you talking about
the one he says he thinks it involved a
police officer and maybe you destroyed
the deck okay so this actually is in we
did an episode of a Tony Hawk on the
on GameSpot I've said at a point and was
one of our last ones we actually
recorded in any of you a Tony Hawk ash
III um this was like before God knows
which one was a Tony Hawk pro skater for
yeah he was on the rounds and we did a
and interviewed him as part of a sort of
it episode I was doing around to have
skate culture blew up after the release
of Tony Hawk I'd meet my love of
skateboarding coming from that as well
and as part of it one of my friends and
Neil and Neil Sheen who runs a really
good YouTube channel about modding up
rowdy cars and Ireland's called juice
box at the you go to youtube.com
I think it's a juice box for you it's
called it's absolutely brilliant it's
blowing up at the moment as well and but
he used to make he write he did skate
videos in my hometown for years and I
used to do scape heroes too but he did
this video was actually my video he did
a video where they got a Tony Hawk ride
board like the the the plastic
peripheral I guess 360 right and you
might have seen it it blew up it was a
he basically drilled a bunch of trucks
onto it and then they started skating it
around our little skate park in my
hometown and Tony Hawk we did it any of
you basically he was in San Francisco so
we were at actually what kind of looks
like this here and amb is one of the
biggest like skate spots and like
American skater history and it's the
Embarcadero it's that reg you know I
read paved area and just at the end of
market um actually really looks like
this
so MB give a ski got they put grinds
Stoppers on it they stop skaters they
killed that spot back in the nineties
and one of the reasons that sort of
people in within skating it's kind of
the counter points of Tony Hawk is that
the problem was when skateboarding blew
up and suddenly there was kids
it was like four times as many people
are going to these public spots that it
basically stopped them from being viable
as skate skate spots anymore kind of
killed the culture and hope people into
skate into into parks and some people
don't like ridin parks so my mate Neil
who did that video was in San Francisco
so we've we went to EMB and we did an
interview and then I interviewed Tony
Hawk about
- sort of quandary the fact that the
games might have actually in a way sort
of hindered endured the culture um yeah
so that was the whole thing and that the
video he did was uh was so funny because
a cop comes up to him like a portly
Irish Garda who's like what you don't
know get off those skateboards you know
you know and stuff you don't suppose for
skateboarding round here I'm there and
the others like it's just a video game
like it's not a real skateboard it's
like you know none of this is real yeah
just buttons it's just it's mock you
know your mind the Garda there's no
wider thoughts he's like it's Xbox it's
on Xbox seems like loads the policeman
the Garda says I will go take care of
affected Xbox down to the park then but
I said it to tell me all Kazan he he
said he saw hot dogs are you funny so
man it was nice to connect the dots for
a good nail we have a nother $50
donation whoa black lives from Richard
Hayes thank you watched it's another
familiar name it's fine I love jumping
in the chat and seeing all these
usernames some of which I can see
everyone so all on noclip stuff and some
of which I haven't seen in that in a
half minute
it's right and it's a really good at
this is like a super cool important
project you guys are are tackling I was
actually really impressed how quickly
you guys pivoted to include and BLM in
it as well yeah me too honestly yeah it
was last minute but it everyone just
felt it was so important to to make
happen
yeah totally isn't it so strange like
the the world we live in now we're just
expectations for things like that change
in a day like just there's so much like
[ __ ] that you were like yeah like I'd
love if they do this like I'd love if
people would give a [ __ ] about this
thing or like isn't this an awful thing
that we all just kind of pretend is like
normal and we can't fix and now it's
just like every day there's like a bunch
of stuff that's happening it feels like
it's it feels like the needle is moving
in the right direction just faster than
it ever has before
in a way that is maybe I feel like it's
scarier for Americans
I feel like this rate of this type of
stuff is more common back in in Europe
this type of like public revolt and big
sweeping change and perhaps it's the
scale of the problem here I don't know
perhaps it's this is the by no means
just an American issue obviously neither
and neither is neither a touch point
where we're talking about here but it is
wild like I was just gonna see I was
just like you know just not the aperture
of nothing I saw NASCAR got rid of the
Confederate flags and you're like holy
[ __ ] like they've been fluffing on that
one for years they ask people to stop
bringing them like five years ago and
they never did I'd like one of these
just like and then suddenly you're like
oh yeah the pressure is there now
everyone has to like it there's a real
like it if you're not for this thing
then you're like you know it's they look
like the white silence thing right like
if you're not if you're not for it then
by default you are you know why you stay
in silence it's kind of the thing that
yeah totally
it's uh it's it's been an exciting time
I mean not I don't know if exciting is
the right word but just I hear seeing
things hat like it like like kinda what
you're saying it seems like the needle
is moving in the right direction even
though it probably took away too much
for that to finally happen like it's
reassuring to see that like it seems
like people are actually trying to make
changes make a difference like fix the
system any way they can even if it is by
small ways that you know at first glance
or by itself may not seem like it's
gonna amount to much but like when you
factor in the fact that everyone is kind
of on this same page I think that is
really exciting to see yeah it's I hear
what you're saying I heard that little
bit of like guilt in your voice when you
said it um I I kind of I appreciate that
because I'm trying to like unpack this a
little bit myself where it's like I mean
in a way I feel excited I'm buoyed by
this but obviously that's easy for me
because I'm a white guy and also I'm not
even an American right so like there's
there's coming from it from a different
perspective right and having the
privilege of being able to be excited
about it not to go through yeah the the
issues the sort of emotional strife that
I'm sure a lot of black people are
emulation
they can't avoid it right now right like
something they probably try and in a way
avoid but I think the thing that I'm
trying to connect to that is that is a
that is positive far from this sick
trick I just did damn it um is it felt
there for a while turn the fan on it
felt like for a while there that we were
all slipping into a darker place like
the momentum was actually going in the
opposite direction yeah
now be the first time it feels like
there's been a little bit of a course
correct and that actually not only is it
feel like it's going in a better
direction but there's people I think for
a long time were very disconnected from
community and disconnected from
political change or kind of feeling
helpless like like they had no power
powerless maybe whereas now it feels
like everyone is buoyed by this sense of
oh no actually turns out if we organize
and point in a similar direction you can
make massive structural change happen in
a weekend like everything seems doable
now and like if ever there was a look
because the big the worst thing about
all this is like not only do have a
pandemic and and the sort of reckoning
of a couple of centuries worth of of
discrimination in this country but the
big ones still gonna come which is
climate change which is even bigger not
to minimize any of those but yeah that's
that's that's gonna require an
incredible amount of change from just
about everyone in the planet so if we
can learn some of these lessons now and
fix some of this stuff and even in in so
doing just kind of learn as a species
how to do this and pass this on to the
next generation then maybe we might be
able to unify around around around that
one and so it feels like it feels
strange to be living in this - I've
suddenly figured out which chapter of
history were living in man it's like or
at least the sense of it or it's like
okay okay I'm like I'm probably not
gonna see a lot of these things actually
come to
Christian and that change but we may
actually push the needle in the right
direction quite a loss and that would be
kind of exciting sorry I'm rambling a
lot no it's all good
they did some people because we have a
couple donations we got Frank Holly who
don't matter
thank you Frank I think Ryan uh Mendez I
think as I say that $25 Thomas right out
another $25 right out my boy thank you
and thick stink with $10 oh yeah I was
thick bent spelled fix pink a CH I are
sorry th ICC oh nice okay I like it yeah
supported like bugs next if they had I
was like the minute they said it I was
like it better be X at the end it has to
be yeah my nails are coarser ice that's
if crowd can can name good videogames
Octodad is also a great name for a game
that's same devs yeah I'm working on
this hell it's 5:00 or like four or five
years uh speaking which you've had a
actually a couple questions in the chat
just asking like what our overall
thoughts on where the on the Sony press
conference yesterday I'd love to hear
what you guys have to say about it
mm-hmm don't take it away something I
don't know there was there was so much I
mean overall I want to say I feel like
almost pretty much every game they
showed I was like I want that I want to
play that like I think their lineup was
just so impressive i I mean we talked we
already talked about definitely open
just how amazing that is uh Demon Souls
like kind of new is coming like when it
when they went blue blue point said like
years ago they're like oh we're working
on a game I was like it's gotta be
demons like yeah no way great didn't
they put out that tweet - that was like
referencing Demon Souls as well as like
eight other different and like red and
just had a field day cuz they were like
it could be Symphony and letter e like
it could be a demon so do you make could
be a blood-borne remake no gear yeah
yeah Metal Gear 3 was a they just took a
bomb
like they just took like a bunch of
words that you know people relate to
those games and not through it into a
sentence that didn't make sense I'm so
excited
not only to play that game by think for
like other people to play that game like
I have played it I've never finished it
though actually so I've been meaning to
go back and finish it so maybe I'll go
back and finally do that before for the
remake comes out but it's just like I
think that games still does things very
uniquely that other later from software
games haven't haven't gone back to which
I think will make that game still feel
feel fresh and interesting you know as
opposed to just like an interesting
curiosity like I think it still holds up
in a lot of really like spectacular ways
because it's almost got this like I know
if you know much how the structure of
the game but basically you can play in
any order you want where you have like
the hub area and then you go to these
different zones that you are like over
time and you can go in any direction you
want in the game so the game is kind of
like intentionally built that way and
then it's I think that like dramatically
changes people's experience to that game
and you'll see a lot of interesting
parallels where you'll see like oh this
is where like the Belgard girls from
Dark Souls originally this is like the
og Bell gargoyles or this is like the og
Blighttown and and I think also that
games way weirder like yeah yes like
yeah it's it's way more Japanese
folklore II maybe and then demons Dark
Souls it's kind of a little bit more a
lot more DNA damn nice I'm more gimmicky
like the bosses the enemy design and
like they they tried a lot of weird
stuff that they've slowly been kind of
like sanding the edges off I feel like
over here it's a bad thing but I do
something about how weird Demon Souls is
that I still love I'm sorry to interrupt
but it looks like we got a donation for
Coke it looks like I just saw a nice
shoot up it looked like it was
definitely a $50 donation for
tim downing Wow thank you so much -
thank you Tim Tim downing also donated
$50 to black lives matter as well
Tim Edie in the place laughing thank you
thanks so much we have billing or
downing downing downing awesome we have
a comment here from Oliver ludie - who
says Danny I got my results back from
that interview and peace I did with you
I got distinctions and all my stuff so
I'm going to college and Galloway soon
go away awesome congratulations that's
her eyes I'm so glad to hear that it's
been a weird year for all the folks back
home because the the way Irish exams
work so you guys do like your SATs right
at the end of the year mm-hmm but you're
also great at rate whatever last two
years of your high school is it or are
like your you sent off stuff to college
based on like stuff you've done already
yes so you send off your like GPA from
the four years you've been a high school
to college and then they take that into
account as well as your SAT scores but I
think your grades are probably more
probably than what you're applying but
yeah it depends on the college so in
Ireland we have we have just a set of
exams at the end of the last year of
high school and that's it your whole
score comes down to two or three-hour
exam you do call and it's called a
leaving certificate and so but they
don't like you don't get like a Jeep a
GPA or any of that sort of stuff
throughout the year and so they didn't
do that this year because Demick so all
these kids who are like what - dude
living search for suddenly like oh we're
cancelling the leading search um so what
they did instead is wild is that they
basically got all the teachers to just
make up the GPA just go through all the
old work I'm not going and they weren't
testing my GPA like you don't sometimes
you do tests in school but it's mostly
just to make sure you learn this top and
the subject yeah and I feel like so I'm
hoping there
likely it'll be incidence II if they
skew higher or lower than usual because
I was a real like cram student like I
was I was I would always do better in
the laughs I would be a see students who
would then get B's in the exams does so
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy so I'm glad that
he's going to go away and when
everything's all right because I know a
lot of folks back home we're having a
bit of a weird one with their exams I
have I have a friend from Ireland who
now goes to Berkeley I think he just
graduated cool and he was telling me
that he was like yeah the way you guys
do testing here it makes is is way less
stressful for me like I can just take
these tests like I can take a couple
tests throughout a semester rather than
just waiting until I'm done to just
write hit all of it at once that's crazy
it's difficult but he was they prepared
us because it was i i'm i'm not i don't
i'm not very scholarly and like that
like but i but for a lot of people it's
a nightmare right because it's yeah
gonna be a really good students but just
that day I had a friend who I had a
buddy who I went to school with cuz I
also did this year called transition
year which is like a year you can take
if you wants and it's kind of like you
can skip it it's a 4th year in high
school out of six and you can do it to
basically explore a bunch of weird
subjects and and do work experience and
stuff like that it was I love that it
was to me it really helped me figure out
what I want to do and might a friend
whose father died while we were in third
year and then I ended up being in school
with his younger brother cuz I did
transition he didn't and the day before
our economics exam which I'm pretty sure
was the last exam both of us were doing
and probably most people and his mother
died both both from cancer and he he
just had to teach us did the exam like
like I think you can defer it and maybe
do it later in the year but like nobody
wants to do that because you basically
spend weeks studying for this two hour
slot and literally the following day we
were all outside and he walked in and
like the whole class gave my big hug and
then he waited and he [ __ ] killed it
as well I think
I think he got like a V or something
which is really hard in economics um
yeah so it's it's it's a really weird
vibe like the leaving start is like it's
just like we do it already and for
there's another one called the junior
search which happens after third year
which is basically like you know just
the same one but you get points in it as
well but it doesn't mean anything like
it doesn't it's it's kind of just like a
dummy wrong for the other one but but
it's so strange and it's also like you
know most schools in Ireland will wear
uniforms but nobody wears uniforms
during the exams because school is
technically closed so it's also kind of
like a weird summer camp vibe to it as
well it's it's a it's a pick it's like a
rite of passage back home it's a strange
sort of thing it's sad that people won't
be able to do that in a way it's kind of
like the graduations over here as well
where kids aren't able to have that last
little hoorah with each other kind of
thing yeah as well you know I've seen
some smaller schools like just have
their cars pull in to like in view from
in the car which seems seems a while at
that point I feel like I just yeah let's
just do it online drive-through diploma
[Laughter]
we also have Taco Bell's open we can do
something you should be able to just
like the diploma if I just graduated
though I'd like gun it out of there
after I got my thing as actual
graduations they're fun but like if just
having to sit there in the ceremoniously
I've like ADHD though so like I just
can't I can't stand sitting in like big
things like that it's wah we did we
never did graduations for high school we
did it for college but we did we don't
have them for for secondary school in
Ireland
Oh Adam from I had a mind for middle
school even which was like wild yeah it
feels pointless it was more it felt more
of like a here's just something to like
make you feel like you're doing
something but like right it's like good
point we're just going my high school
was like literally was across the street
from the middle school
so it's like this doesn't mean anything
like rude man crossing the street yeah I
was in a weird thing in college because
my my degree was like I think we were
the first year to do it
multimedia and it's basically like web
development and a bunch of like audio
production and stuff when I was a bug um
the end so my so I guess because it was
a new course they were trying this like
split thing so technically it wasn't a
four-year course it was a two-year
something certificate third the third
year to get to diploma and the fourth
year to get to degree so I actually had
three graduations I could have gone to I
didn't go to the other two and I barely
went to the third one I mean but it was
yeah I was it was kind of that was like
overkill I was like after never having a
graduation high school then it was like
almost one every year we have another
$25 donation black lives from right
Mena's again Wow Ryan Ryan just felt the
need yeah huge shot a team man
when you think about it it's Friday this
is usually be a day you might like I get
with some friends after work have a
couple of jars maybe grab some foods
maybe taken maybe take a cab home
Trevor taking cabs in the old world
remember that [ __ ] so like who knows you
got it you got a couple of bucks to
spare you're not going that cop you're
not you're probably drinking at home
maybe we're all drinking at home
we're probably drinking more than we
used to maybe for some reason nothing to
do with what's going on in the world you
know just maybe spin drop a couple of
bucks here yeah and if you'd like to
donate the links are down there black
lives matters you can donate a bit oddly
/gs - BLM and then for kovat relief you
can donate it bit la / - yes - co vid
those links are also showing up in the
chat as well in both YouTube and twitch
so either one of those you should be
able to find something pretty easily and
thank you to chastity for just doing the
tweet and tagging me
appreciate it just a little wreath right
there as well
sort of been slowly adding parks to this
thing there's a bunch of [ __ ] join me
show you something gay maybe some of the
little bits yeah it's cool this game is
on Steam early access um it's pretty
good there's a decent mount of stuff in
there if you play these games like me
which is basically to just to play just
to go hit some spots and it's not
there's no like challenges or any of
that stuff um oh he says as he messes
over the challenges section here police
slide session oh cool any sixteen grind
slides on any of the eight Police Plaza
ledges that's cool I didn't no idea
these were here I've been playing this I
have like a hundred hours of this game
historical oh cool that's all the ones
you've done in the past I guess buttery
backside you have to do a backside 360
nollie impossible seven hundred two
hundred and seventy two times and then
you'll get fifty two dollars that
doesn't seem worth it um it seems like
some destiny grinding right there yeah
they have a bunch of weird stuff here
like they have a I think this is the
multiplayer filming thing is it and then
they have a game of skates you can do
they don't have bi grabs are kind of in
here but they turn them off by default
and then I don't actually know the map
layouts and it's like VHS menu style
layout like I go and I saw the UH I
think it was like the control oh yeah it
looks like like VHS like man or you'd
get yeah totally it's got its got like
the s-video to the thing at the bottom
yeah that's so good it's pretty yeah
dan AKA neurosis has stopped by the
twitter how you doing ian horrocks yeah
twitch his own he runs the show he can
turn him out an instant if he wants they
also think we're too good see that so I
work where we're gonna say Jake oh I was
just gonna say we have another donation
ooh
hell yeah you can come in even Strome
$25 for black lives matter
thank you so much too oh and watch $25
to Cove
as well watch love crew oh I think I
just saw another donation pop in
I guess you're seeing it sooner than I
probably see us you may have just read
that one there yeah yeah this little
apartment here as well which you can
watch your old videos if you recorded
any oh I guess that's the menu is it is
that just what that is
oh no yeah there's a bit some things in
here um that's the same one smart and
now he says I got to prepare for a shoe
thank you all for watching
Danny love you and miss you and buddy
keep doing our beards you're killing it
did you guys ever see me you guys ever
see that a total man it's that's it's
that skating movie that came out a
couple years ago
directed by can I do some embers
documentary movie it wasn't talked to
him it was a movie I know wasn't dog
tansy boys what was it oh yeah the M
[Music]
there's two I'm thinking of those
there's
the one with the kids who lives in like
the shitty part of town and there later
on again
dad let's get crew that's the one that I
yeah okay yeah I forget the name of it I
look it up mm-hm there's like very
little customization here there's a
couple they got some stuff in here like
I think I've what do I have on have you
played a thug Pro at all
thug pro pro it's like a modded version
of underground - like oh that's right
I haven't is it on pc then so thug pro i
love it
yeah it's weird my favorite was always
it's kind of like the mario kart thing
we're like your favorite is the first
one you played you know like my - so
yeah and i think three is maybe a better
game but two is mine cuz you know I used
to jump ran that I had it like I like a
lot of European people I had a like a
love of like American sort of culture as
much as I had a love of skateboarding
culture right so there was you know my
favorite bands growing up or like
Deftones who are in sacramento and you
know it's it's wild now that I have a
kid who will go to an American school
because like to me American schools are
like skate parks is mid-90s by the way
that's the movie I was thinking it's all
mid-90s no that was dead yeah that was
the one directed by what's his face from
Moneyball and yeah it's mad what's his
name I can't say that throat no not Seth
Rogen what's the other guy's name
watch out help set mmm someone knows
sure I don't know how I can remember I
saw it I know I've got long ago and I
remember really enjoying it and really
good like my my childhood definitely
wasn't that stressful but like the whole
skater culture I definitely remember cuz
I'd hang out at skate parks all the time
and like I pick my skateboard with me
everywhere and like parts of it I was
like man this and growing up in the
mid-90s - I was like yeah I remember a
lot of this or early 2000s late 90s I
guess somebody has a minidisc player one
stage I think it's
like a real foggy bear says Jonah Hill
Jonah Hill thank you foggy bear man [ __ ]
you bears in both chats oh man she's
mattress pointed out fug Pro it's a it's
a mod for underground - on the piece
like a total crude mod it's got a really
cool community
and people do wild [ __ ] in that thing I
definitely recommend checking it out
that's cool I love all these little mod
communities birds we're doing a I'm
editing at the moment a documentary on
command & Conquer remastered mm-hmm
interview to watch the folks who were
working on that and it's been fun they
basically set up a community cancel and
this is EA mind you they set up a like a
like a group of modders and people who
like hacked the games so you could still
play it online and all these things and
they were basically involved with threat
development actually they were involved
before development started and they
would like okay designs and give
feedback on like graphics and audio and
like it was it's this crazy situation
where like the equivalent would be like
when they're making the new Tony Hawk
getting all these thug pro people to
basically okay the new designs and stuff
like that right and it's super cool and
it's interesting cuz it's like I can't
they they nailed that remaster which
means my pet Raqqah who are basically
that is what Westwood Studios kind of
West were divided into the folks that
went to EA LA and the folks that stayed
in Las Vegas and they state that they
went to Patrick Burke mm-hm
so it's basically the same people but
yeah digital foundry video and I was
just so impressed with with how it
looked like all the original like videos
and stuff looked like so I you would
just like assume that stuff would be
like lost a time and it would be like
the super like crappy compressed file
but like they were able to like find
those original files or high notes oh
yeah we have it in the talk but
basically and I know Jim for sellers
like they were pretty transparent about
all this when it was going on but they
they couldn't find the original tapes
and then they thought they found the
tapes and then they were
VHS backups or Betamax backups
uncompressed versions so what they ended
up doing was frank klepacki who's the
guy who teased a composer or the
original cnc and like the original like
dune - and all this stuff guys a legend
and he wasn't the audio guy on the game
he only did music but he went back
through and remastered all the audio for
them and then they basically holds the
console versions cuz they were slightly
higher resolution than the PC ones and
then they used machine learning to
basically uh press them Wow yeah they
found an algorithm that worked after
months of playing with it with the
community the community had basically
already done a lot of this work they had
this is hair they had fixed the problem
so they basically through the power of
sort of like petroglyph NDAA behind
trying to find like the best possible
way of uprising it and yeah they used
machine learning to to make them better
so it's it's it's weird it's like they
actually didn't it's something that like
five years ago we were able to do that
yeah and it looks good like I just
assumed like oh they must have found
like the og files I get looks amazing
Wow dude yeah man shout out like you
know modders they keep they keep our
games live in ways where you know you
have all those like older games where
companies didn't do the best job
preserving you know the code or whatever
and modders they find a way there's so
many games like communities that just
about stuck around enough for a studio
to do a to do a sequel like
counter-strike is a obviously a big one
where most of the people who stuck
around were actually and I'm a source
fan but most of the people were at that
1.6 community but stuck around then when
csgo came out I think a lot of people
who were working on it records kind of
strike players or a lot of people who
are like sort of they who built the
foundations of the csgo community which
is their massive it was all from that so
it's cool not to mention the fact that
that is a mod like dota and like so many
things that's a great we've lost we've
lost a a strata of game culture in
recent years with the lack
for modding you met a control that that
studios are doing and hopefully like I
know with the with the canonic conquer
remake they opened it up to they did two
things actually two crazy things which
are again are very on EA like which was
they released the source code for C&C a
week before remaster came out and I made
it like fully usable legally and then
they also AM opened up Steam Workshop
support for CNC remastered as well so
you know [ __ ] years ago they were
they didn't have games on Steam origin
right now they're like doing all this
mad [ __ ] so yeah the whole thing is
because like it's it's clearly a a them
trying to reckon with her their standing
within gaming because the guns
backlash to that command & Conquer
mobile game that they you know instance
2018 that that's why this whole game
came together because they saw the
backlash and we're like oh we need to
yeah yeah what am i my favourite like
obscure Studios night dive studios
they're the guys who enhanced editions
of System Shock and they're doing like
that reef that remake of System Shock 1
because they they're like bread and
butter is just like finding the most
random obscure PC games and like getting
them to run Windows 10 like you know you
got things like System Shock but then
you got like honestly not good games
like harvester that are just like
terrible but like they're doing that
work yeah yeah yeah and I'm like God
bless you God bless you for bringing to
you obscure not great you know games
from the 90s but but letting people play
them in 2018 that's amazing not to
constantly be pimping noclip stuff but
we also have a an interview at steven
from nine type studios going up in the
next month Jeremy's editing it at the
moment I think I've been hoping you
would do something around them we
recorded it at GDC last year so it's
been
but yeah we tell the story of how he and
he bought the rights to systems
he's like an eBay guy who like he's like
a young dude like Stephens like my age I
think I guess I bought by own like you
know I think he said is like 30s and
he's just like he's like somebody who's
on eBay at four o'clock in the morning
but instead of like buying like [ __ ]
obscure like you know name Boz does he's
like he's buying videogame ip's did
nobody's like people hundr vaping for
some reason yeah shark was always the
crazy one because I remember everyone
being like yeah you'll probably never
see anything with System Shock ever
again because it's like held by some
random guy holding company like it was
like all these like weird layers of five
people owned - all this [ __ ] yeah weird
yeah we could we do in our GOG video we
covered some of like the the weird
things that happen when companies go
bankrupt when they own ip's and I peas
end up getting like fragmented to all
these different companies and like as
you know in investment groups and like
who don't even know what's on their
portfolio don't even know what they have
and they don't they don't have like an
arm that will sell us like them don't
spit out their portfolio it's just all
this weird business puzzlement that has
to go on so that we can play [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] legacy of kain or daikatana
or something it's just like so strange
the network reclaim the amount of work
that like that gog team goes through to
get those games on the storefront is
nuts like i had no idea until i watched
that documentary that you guys did and i
was like I was like thing that's really
impressive like it was impressive at
first to see a lot of those games but
you just don't really understand all the
work in like how yeah like you're saying
how much of a puzzle it is just to like
wasn't there one anecdote in that thing
where they were like yeah the code was
like printed up and some person's hat
like there's just some really absurd
place yeah it was written it was that
they didn't find the code but somebody
had a printout of all the code
[Laughter]
it's so strange because you assume that
the the lion's share of the work on
those is like programming and
compatibility and actually GOG leans on
like DOSBox for a lot of that stuff and
a lot of like custom wrappers for them
and stuff like that may have programmers
there but a lot of it is a it's just
business and that's and that's why I
like no one lives forever is the one
that they've they've gotten so many of
them like they have they've gotten they
had like five or six games that people
thought we'd never see and they
basically have five of them done but the
last one that no one can seem to get is
no one that's forever and they've been
working on there for years and it's just
caught up in a licensing nightmare where
somebody's holding out or doesn't care
or it's in like a family dispute or
something like that you know like
somebody's ass tastes like it's just
something bizarre we just want to play
this like 60 style FPS although you know
maybe death loop is taking a little bit
of no one left ever kind of style I
don't know I'd imagine they eat Reds the
years of back and for it yeah totally
like just following up again you know
every six months that's that's one of
the guys you interview said he's just
like it's like that you just like you
just you know it's a lot of
communicating with people know these
elevators weird polish company called CD
Projekt who are like you know asking
because they're part of the CD Projekt
group they're they're not CD Projekt reg
but they're part of sort of CD Projekt I
wonder if that wonder if the success of
CD Projekt RED has either made it easier
or harder because on the one hand they
have the name recognition by the other
hand I can see those people being like
asking for more money yeah see for it
you know
that's a good point there's like recent
headlines about her like CD Projekt are
now the biggest developer in Europe I
think they just surpassed Ubisoft um
which I mean Ubisoft also studios and a
lot of them in Canada so I'm not sure if
that includes those two maybe it does
yeah cost of our development is
certainly cheaper in Poland and they
have also managed to sort of like latch
on to a lot of the Polish development
challenge because you got a lot of these
Ireland's quite like this to where you
have like a high level of like people
are going to college cuz college is you
know I think it's free there too and a
lot of people who are good at
programming and engineering and those
types of jobs but a lot of them leave
right they go to countries where they
can earn a lot more money and Polish
people certainly we're going to a lot of
countries in Europe for years because
the the slotty against the euro was so
advantageous you could go to work and
I'd friends polish friends work in
Ireland who would work there for like
four or five years and then go home
because they had the deposit for a house
you know and so they've managed to
retain a lot of those people in Warsaw
and it's getting harder because there's
like I've really [ __ ] up right-wing
government there and their constitutions
getting torn apart and they're sort of
in like the liberal Center in Warsaw but
these other ways in which life is
becoming kind of less fun in Poland so
they've managed to you're a big big
studio bigger than we were last time I
went there and I was like it only
bubbled up to 350 I think by that stage
as well getting sick in a skatepark my
go somewhere else all right well that's
a good time to remind everybody that we
are doing this live stream with Danny
because we are raising money for both
black lives matter and co vid 19 Direct
Relief you can see the URLs both on the
stream right here as well as in the
description so please if you have some
spare money as Danny mentioned it's the
Friday take the money you would normally
spend taken to go back see a Taco Bell
about five bucks you're gonna spend on
fifty eight tacos a Taco Bell guess
what'll make you sick exact as good as
they are yes or you know somebody who is
willing to donate or have some money
direct them to the stream get some
people in it's about my family
spam day Twitter's turned into the
[ __ ] Wild West folks we're all just
like retweeting about the protests and
and everything it's like it's it's
there's never been a better time to just
smash smash that arty button like
and like you like it's going out of
fashion just do it it's all for good
cause absolutely in fact we actually
just got a donation as we were talking
about that from shell comics who donated
$25 to black lives matter young comics
part of the noclip community one of our
stalwarts in india what time is it in
India at the moment what is it what are
we here it's it's 1 p.m. here India it's
like we are we mid mice is it midnight
hold it up yeah see thank you
yeah thank you appreciate it thank you
guys for doing a stream I always feel
awkward asking for donations because my
company is a donation it's hard to ask
people to donate again a half hours
ahead of us so it's currently 1:30 in
the morning
Wow burn those hey it's Friday night
this is what you do remember used to go
out party right stay in a party
is the station oh yeah it's a it's not
it's it's not massive like the New York
area I was in at the start was kind of
the biggest area um and then there's
kind of like a bunch of these maps
they're like they're a good size though
because like you know the thing about
skating games that you're essentially
doing the same like four things over and
over again
Nikita grinding or doing a bit of bird
or you doing flatland stuff or you know
whatever nobody grabs in this book you
didn't bits and bobs and then it's just
all about lines it's all about like just
having a variety of things that are
different heights different lengths and
then having the lines that sort of you
know put them together what I like I
made this game is that it's actually
kind of it's less like a Tony Hawk
Rescate where you can kind of find lines
anywhere and this when you kind of have
to go searching for them kind of like in
real life for you realize oh actually
these two things are good and they're
close enough that I can like this for
instance this is actually a really bad
run-up like there's no good way to grind
this like you don't really have enough
speed here it depends if you're regular
or goofy of course but like if I'm if
I'm goofy here I can try this it's it's
I'm facing the right way but I don't
have enough time to get the speed and if
I'm goofy on this one I probably don't
want to go in on my back towards this it
might I don't know it depends I guess
company where I but there's not really
that much of a enough space to line up
and also get the shallow angle you need
to hit it so that's cool cuz in another
game they probably like open this up a
little bit for you what what I like
about this one is you kind of have to
like oh maybe this stair sets better
look at this stair set like what a
shitty exit but it's cool cuz it's like
you can you can just decide to do it or
decide to do like a different thing or
it's it's not um it's not it's not like
a theme park where everything is in its
why it's like more realistic and messy
and it's kind of fun because it means
you have to go searching for [ __ ] like
all right like this one's kind of good
this is probably a bit longer than I'd
like to do um so you know what I'll go
some rounds it's go downstairs to
dessert
I feel good it's a big part of
skateboarding too that doesn't usually
get translated to many of the games just
cuz yeah like what you're saying they
are designed to just like here's a
little theme park of all the
things you can hit so I do really like
that it's fun it's it yeah it's weird
it's like when you first when I first
played the New York level remember
thinking like wow where is everything
and then you finally could go through an
area and be like oh there's like a whole
other part of the city here but they
don't like Telegraph it to you know my
open-world games where like there's a
big like point of interest so you're
like oh there must be something over
there and you go to our totally I
exactly Atari I just like Far Cry our
way through the game but it's a yeah so
it's kind of a little more subtle and it
works so this is like a fun one I cuz it
has a little bit of a pop up and then it
has its there so this is Jake what did
you think of the PlayStation stuff Jake
before you say that we have a influx of
donations
you're a ish mathur hope I'm saying that
correctly donated two hundred and fifty
dollars to blow ASAS mathur ish mathur a
y OS H is Mathur thank you thank you my
heart
that is incredible also your nails is
incredible they're incredibly met first
an incredible man o3 this year so we
have to be you're incredible
we also have from Jack Williams $25 to
black lives matter so much Jackie and
then from Phil row $10 to ball this
matter nice Thank You Phil and then
finally from Jeffrey Fogle $25 to
blacklivesmatter mr. Fogle thank you so
much Williams thank you so much my bill
name is William William power beep
William power be with you I don't know
I'm making a religious and who's the
third person there is Phil Roe Phil Roe
third in a row thank you so much Phil
appreciate it you're all beautiful
people I hope I know you're craving that
[ __ ] nachos Bella Grande but you know
we really appreciate wasting your taco
money on us
taco Berlin I have been to a Taco Bell
in the past week
drive-through Taco Bell is
is maybe the most like post-apocalyptic
thing I've done since it was like was it
which what was it in a it's pretty
tomorrow's not here because I think it
was in a what was that Sly Stallone
movie with the clams climbed the three
clams and the Oh what is it
[ __ ] man yeah demolition I think Taco
Bell's and demolition man yeah yeah it's
like the in the future all the
restaurant franchises at each other and
Taco Bell one so every restaurant is
Taco Bell okay so it's like going to
talk about and like like now it's like
they hand out the credit card machine to
you and it comes in like a special bag
that's already been prepared before and
like everyone's wearing like [ __ ]
hazmat suits it's just like and you're
behind you're doing this like you know
I'm just like the one risky thing I do
every week is get or not everybody but
like you know go to the grocery store
and then like I'll do a risk he's like
way up your risks with covert 19 and I
decided to waste it on [ __ ] five
dollar tacos there was a car alarm
blaring in my window so I muted myself
but if you heard any of that I apologize
I did I was just kept going and going
and going it's like we're good now we
have a question here from Daniel Moreno
who is in our GameSpot discord and as is
a great date but he says question what
piece of what piece of community such
backer feedback can you recall that
helped the production side of no clip
from that point or if you can talk about
the evolution of your content over time
sure great question [ __ ]
that's a brilliant student backer hmm
we've got a lot of criticism of our
captions on our final fantasy
documentary which was really helpful in
a sort of layering in a couple of
different production and by changing the
timeline of production to better fish
the clarification of those captions
because it also influences editor
so for our cane doc for instance we
managed the captions were nailed and
they went through several different
people we did I passes and Megan Karns
who does all our captions did a couple
of passes on us and not just for the
accuracy but also formatting a captions
it's really important and we had our
French peep we'd have we'd French
speakers look at them we had an
interpreter who was with me when I did
the interviews I also go over them and
clarify and so we have to do all of this
again for our prey and dishonor docks
which will be coming in July but that
that ended up working really good and
then also up as a bonus to that and
Bethesda's localization crew took what
we had done in the english captions and
converted it into seven I think separate
languages from that they managed to turn
those over in about a week so dang that
was really good it helped a little bit
that I have some French so I was able to
Indianness for instance it was I could
understand where they were stopping
sentences and phrases and stuff like in
you know obviously when you anything
people are editing any B's you tend to
do a lot of cutting people off half
sentence if it's redundant or getting
rid of them there's no that [ __ ] wears
in Japanese that's way harder because of
the way Japanese sentence so structured
and also I don't know any Japanese so
that's why our final fantasy talks also
kind of longer than they need to be like
they probably are about like 15 percent
longer than I like but it's cuz I
couldn't do a lot of that sort of
trimming yeah so that's probably maybe
that's it I'm trying to concern anything
else that's it's like interesting I mean
we listen to feedback all the time and
it's I think it's more of a that was one
of the most direct examples but it's a
lot of just kind of like looking at the
windsock before you know looking at the
flag on you know before you take your
swing where it's it's one of the
considerations but it's not it's not
everything that it's up it doesn't
account for every decision you make
I will say at the stars for the first
couple of years I had a real tendency to
try and make sure that we were kind of
doing a lot of different types of work
because we have patrons who are say wait
they'd support this because they they
want us to do indie stuff and indie
stuff let's get covered you know as much
or whatever or like or they they they
watch the Bears the one I'm like wow you
got into Bethesda that never happens I
want to see more big game stuff you know
and we're a really small team with
myself and Jeremy Jane who added
everything so or 99% of stuff but Esther
by Martinez did an awesome job one on
one of our Docs as well and if you like
our stuff you should check out his
channel Holbach to block he does
basically it's like no clip of fighting
games cuz we don't know [ __ ] about
fighting games now communities kind of
its own kooky one yeah he worked on that
was really good well done yeah I was
routed wasn't it I'm a he just released
his killer instinct documentary its
inherent forty minutes oh yeah people
have blown up about it I was watching
Derek he was tweeting about it people
ready into it um but a yeah we're a
small team so it's it's kind of hard to
you know make locate everyone but and I
think what's cool now is that we've kind
of done so much work that people kind of
trust us like they know we've done big
games they know we've done small games
they know we've done dark secret games
you've heard about in other ones you
have it but I've completely stopped
trying to gauge what will be wanna be
popular or not like some of the [ __ ]
that goes up I think is gonna be like oh
this will be huge and it's like yeah I
guess people were kind of worn out on
that and and sometimes I'm like oh
there's a game that I really like I want
to put this up and see what how like we
just put up our Dwarf Fortress thing and
it's like [ __ ] it whatever popular
videos for everyone I think it is
because it's like cuz I [ __ ] love it
and like but I just didn't think war
fortress at like SEO or whatever and I'm
like we don't do stuff for SEO but like
obviously when you're making something
you have an idea of like I was Karen's
gonna hit the ear you know so so that
was that's like a fun surprise I mean
Jake definitely have that as well or
yeah I think we should do really well
and then like it doesn't and then door
for rent video on something that you
blew up
no way this is doing well I'm just gonna
do this because I want it to be up and
then it does well and you're like
alright well now I'm eating my own words
I I do want to point out that temor has
returned to the chat demolition spam has
returned because people are talking
about demolition man his Tannen summoned
I heard demolition man being mentioned
so he's back he's back in at everyone
yeah we were talking about Taco Bell
buddy we got a couple ordered donations
we have another $25 from shell comics
for black lives matter oh wow thank you
so much
and then Jack Williams who had donated
black lives matter earlier has now
donated $20 fork ovid Wow thank you so
much that's very much a watch of you
guys raised like 22 grand or something
about the princess and we got I mean
four weeks left of this - so oh yeah we
doing it for six weeks not for six weeks
yeah Danny it's a lot it's a lot if you
need me back for another one I'll be
happy to I'm sure yeah
if it's the case I'm sure like people
will graciously hit you up can I talk
about some of my playstation stuff ok
thank you so much I was at I was on
Geoff Keighley summer jams on his a live
show for the pre and post-show for it so
apologies if you've already heard me
rambling about some of the sort of stuff
and obviously we did something Johnny
talked about that live before we started
that was like one of the coolest things
and I love hitman like like no no
surprise there like every you know it's
been known that we did it we did a doc
on him in last summer and mm you know
it's even before that it was common
knowledge that hitman was going to come
back and I'd much I think they'd even
said there was gonna be a trilogy by
that stage already and I knew it was
called everyone was coming but like to
see it and then to see it was in January
it's just like
[ __ ] I'm so happy 9 those guys I'm very
happy at like the way those games have
been being received and like the
popularity I guess I know they're not
huge but still considering how good they
are and how I feel like I'm there look
that first hitman one was or overlooked
that I guess cuz man I had so much fun
with it man 2016 and even like hitman
blood money is still I still think so
fondly about that game him yeah that for
me I like I loved Blood Money so much
and absolution was like okay but it's
just like it wasn't it wasn't what I
wanted and I I just sort of find myself
like I don't think I'll ever get blood
money I'll never get that itch but yeah
I'm an ant and and they were sort of
like after the square Enix thing like
there was a real worry there that IO
Interactive wouldn't be around anymore
right and just need to see to turn
around especially after that the
backlash to the episodic stuff which is
so unfortunate because like it 100%
worked for that game like it made it a
better game like but the sort of
conversation is going on around that
stuff in the periphery where people
remember studios were sort of like
people felt like they were being nickel
and dimed for content which was
completely understandable but it just
wasn't really the case for for them and
also they just are not a big studio so
they have they had to get the game era
piecemeal and also it worked from a
gameplay perspective because there were
those are levels you meant to play over
and over and over again
I'm so glad they've managed to sort of
shake free of that criticism and also
it's just they've leaned into this sort
of bizarre tone of those games like yeah
what's-his-name the [ __ ] the model Oh
his name had the Kruger yeah like like I
think they were they were worried that
people maybe wouldn't fight the same way
as that but like the audience is totally
in lockstep with him on that I think
I was gonna say the the last level of
the second one hitman - where you go to
that like weird like rich person society
and they're all its so yeah the final
level the the Ark thing yeah it's it's
weirdly uncomfortable because they're
like talking about how like they all
know that like climate change is real
but they're all just like not gonna do
anything and hide in there like weird
rich person bunker and I'm just like it
adds his level of like oh this is gonna
be really satisfying specimens people I
was gonna say with hit me in 2016 I
remember be being one of those people
not that I necessarily thought it was a
ripoff I just wanted to wait for the
entire thing to come out and play it all
in one sitting and I remember after I
played through the first two I was like
after the first two missions of it I was
like man I should been playing this as I
went I missed out on so much in like
it's clear that I should be replaying
these missions yeah which I should have
thought of because that's something I
definitely did in Blood Money right like
I remember playing the Suburbia mission
like god probably 3040 times just
loading it up and trying different
things totally I did the exact same
thing like I I it's even more best
intentions I think it's just there was
something about we just weren't used to
it like they were they were kind of a
couple of steps ahead of the curve and
it didn't it actually is sometimes that
works out and sometimes that actually
happens here detriment so yeah it's it's
a bit of a shame but yeah yeah I'm right
there with you when you think about
people like there's a lot of people who
like never actually played the full
version of hitman code 47 like the first
one but they kind of think they did
because they played the demo like for 20
hours yeah
what else can I think what else from the
PlayStation the actual system mean J
we're talking about this a little bit
before oh how it looks yeah what do you
think oh it's a [ __ ] beautiful
nightmare it's yes oh it's so bad it's
like it's so bad I love it it's a
consoles have become like the the sort
of like goal of consoles over the past
couple of generations has been to fade
into the background of your set of your
room to set up like they're shown you
know trying to take over the living room
and and then and I think you know that's
made for some fine-looking pieces of
consumer technology that are really
uninteresting like I want my gamecube
handle I want you know just like stupid
looking grilles on stuff and this thing
just looks like Alienware made a [ __ ]
router it's just it's so stupid looking
and it's you know big yeah the
comparisons stuff I've been seeing
people trying to Jimmy oh looks
ridiculous it's just it's glorious I'm
so happy it's it's the worst looking
thing 100 to say you leave speaking my
language I am so I'm so over like gray
black boxes I'm just like I don't want
that I don't want that anymore I want a
a weird ass looking mess of a device
totally it's like if I'm gonna spend
this thing's probably gonna be pricey
right they got two screws which means
one of them is gonna be really expensive
so like and let's be honest like
consoles probably should be more
expensive like they've not gone up
inflation has gone up like the awesome
games hasn't gone up that's why we have
games as a service now like like it kind
of makes sense we can't balk at $600
anymore like I'd be worried if the other
if the one with the drives 700 at this
stage cuz like 4k blu-ray players I've
got one back there they're like a
hundred bucks like they're not cheap so
you know I I think it's gonna be pretty
expensive and you know what else is
expensive and a waste of money is
[ __ ] modern art and this you get both
this is a gaudy statue that you can keep
in your living room and also it plays
[ __ ] 4k movies which cost $40 each
and
also videogames so awesome
it's brilliant why not
it's 2020 there are new rules anymore
well everyone's risking everyone's you
know taking a look at their lives and
changing stuff and in our disk or I
think it was in a discord someone shared
a Photoshop Oh like I'm sure you've seen
plenty of them by now but the one I
liked a lot was they basically turned
the console into a coat because you know
it's got those little flaps on the put a
head on it and arms and just like that
white thing looks like it could like I
like that one yeah totally it's gonna
look it's going you just know it's going
to cuz it already is unlucky
contemporary you know it's going to age
like wet apple it's just gonna oh I love
it look so stupid so quick or they're
weirdly added a curve and that's like
yeah or everyone's got swings you headed
it looks like it like a Quantic Dream
gains future yes it's like yeah the cage
made this console yeah exactly
it's so like this is what people
expected Apple products to look like
before like the iPods and stuff when
they're before like you know those
circular IMAX there was this look all
futuristic yeah this is like a college
project where somebody is there they
were told in their college graphic
design course to like imagine what an
iPod would look like in 20 there's no
style at all but it sort of has the yeah
it's futuristic looking in a sort of a
overly overt sort of way should you guys
are you guys partial to the PS 5 design
over the Xbox one like that's kind of a
weird question cuz I feel like there's
not really I mean there is a design with
the expert or the Xbox Series X but I
know it is just kind of like a column
yeah well I did why I did say that I am
like not into like just boring black
boxes
I like how they made the biggest boring
black box like it has that monolithic
power design so like
I mean of that I think that's like
interesting yeah I agree
it's it's a it is artistic and it's sort
of a minimalism it's not it's not just
it's not like perfunctory looking like
it kind of actually looks like it's
making its own weird artistic statements
but it's just it's like it's the
difference between like you know I don't
know it's like different types of modern
art right like that's sort of like a
minimalist oh Jesus um you know look and
then something a bit more trying to grab
your eye so weird what our game yeah
outside of it horizon zero dawn Midwest
very excited for that
I really like my Kirsten I can I tell us
can I tell a story we've never been able
to salad noclip before I'm actually
allowed to say this but I'm just gonna
say it anyway because that's past so
years and years ago I remember I
remember we used to tell the story on
noclip that there was a game that we
were doing a talk about this when we
were doing the interviews we went into
one of the rooms and accidentally there
was a whiteboard that had the name of
the sequel and the entire map for the
game and and and now net finally I won't
say what game but now that game is
villainized so we already knew there's a
lot of that for quite a while but it was
the matter which had happened was really
funny because we were put in the room
and then PR came into the room and was
like can you ignore it and we're like
yep don't worry about it like there I oh
god yeah we saw people working I like I
won't say anything else but like we we
saw it we were able to then join the
dots with other stuff we had seen while
we were there so it was kind of like I
was like oh that's really exciting I
like that direction so um yeah it's cool
that that is finally out we don't have
to I've
I've had a similar experience I won't
say what it was for but like I went to a
wood to studio and they were they had
announced the game but they hadn't
showed anything on it
and they gave me a whole tour and
they're like if you see anything on
monitors you didn't see it and I was
like alright and I tried not to look but
of course as monitors everywhere and I
saw some stuff that I was very excited
about but it was like I can't say a word
for a very long time it's wild and I was
waiting for this one for a while cuz it
was yeah
I just felt like every III I was like I
wonder if this year I'll show I think no
all right and then kind of felt like it
was gonna happen this time
Jack it's cool anyway on a different
note I'm really excited to play the new
looks rad yeah I'm super excited for
Resident Evil 8 6 I haven't played it
wait seven is the VR one yeah yeah I saw
them play to have a 90 percent step 7th
grade
oh good I don't know if you see much of
what they were showing about 8 because
cuz they showed the trailer but they
also reveal some other details about it
I know I don't know anything else if
shown like they've shown the UI and it's
straight up has like the attache case
with like the Resident Evil 4 Tetris
menu it you can see a currency system
you know they're talking about how it's
like the map is more exploration based
on 7 and I'm just sitting here being
like if you're telling me that this is
basically or - like a 4 - but with like
the survival horror elements of 7 yeah
this is I thought it was a I thought it
was a remake of 4 when I was watching
like within the first 20 seconds of that
trailer I was like oh this is ready for
those these guys look like the what I
call they get a guy yeah yeah yeah I got
yeah it like it looked like them they
had a lot of the same like there was a
dude with looked like a big hammer
jumping off a building and had the same
art pilot I was like this is totally for
and like by the end I was convinced and
then when I came up and said it was 8 I
was like confused and a little maybe
disappointed in their way and then
a minute later I was like oh no I guess
they're just doing eight but they're
kind of doing doing a four stall version
but to hear that they're doing the radio
like the like you the inventory system
that way and stuff as long as you don't
have to cart around you know the
president's daughter for the whole thing
I'll be happy yeah I mean because
there's a rumor that like oh they're
gonna do a remake of four but now
they've confirmed us haven't they maybe
they died a couple of months ago I
thought a couple of months ago there was
they said that they were doing this
review three so the way I thought
they're going where it's kind of like a
weird version of four I'm like do I do I
even need a remake of four at this point
if you're like yeah yeah I look so good
it's got that like oh like Gothic like
blood-borne type of architecture to it I
was gonna say I'm I'm happy but they're
werewolves - let's make we're not scary
I'm true see what they do cuz like
werewolves in blood-borne were scary but
not like scary in the way that I feel
like a Resident Evil game could make
them scary they were scary because they
could just like kick your ass you
weren't paying attention but that made
me excited because I feel like that's
especially now like that's something
that you don't see in survival horror
video games like you don't see
werewolves ya know wide Twilight [ __ ]
everyone I know [ __ ] Sparkle Sparkle
Matt Padgett in the chat has posted the
links for both of our donations black
lives matter and kovat 19 just as a
reminder we are raising money for both
of those organizations to help those
people outs we also have a $5 donation
for black lives matter from I'm gonna
try really hard to get this last name
cracked it's a boffo D Brooke Heller I
hope I would say I always say Dibakar
earlier but I'm not sure if that's
correct either okay okay I was another
part of the noclip fam
thank you so much I don't need five
dollars thank you so much I'm killing
this rail all for you Bob Oh Matt's got
an interesting sir he said we use
at the coalition four gears five they
said they had a secret character they
were going to announce at launch and I
said Dave Batista is Marcus Fenix they
laughed in an announced a pistas Marcus
Fenix not as Marcus Fenix but they've
David IgE
I have a friend who works at Infinity
Ward and he was like he's like yeah we
got some cool things coming up and I was
like battle royale for modern warfare
and he just looked at me and shook his
head I mean that there was leaked so
many times before yeah I didn't feel bad
Smart Hub G's in a really weird place
now they [ __ ] hate it now like here
and there I haven't played properly in a
couple of months but I have played in
the past few weeks just like game here
or there and got it bots to it and did a
bunch of weird stuff and it's coming out
yeah it's not a great spot I've been
wanting to dip back into that game
because I played so much of it and I've
been playing all these other battle
royale games and a lot of them like on
paper I think are probably better but
there's something about pub G that
that's just it's so hard to replicate
nothing else has scratched it's for me
no other game is yeah I get it I totally
get it
I just love how you I love the realistic
style leanings of us like it reminds me
of playing games like Rainbow six and
like ARMA and ARMA operation flashpoint
stuff like that you know it's it's in
that lineage a bit more
we're like early 2000 2001 feel totally
to it I miss all those types of games
like I keep [ __ ] switching trying to
do this thing we've been like cuz I
really enjoyed Ghost Recon break point
for what it was but like as someone who
really liked those older games it was
kind of like oh this isn't quite what I
was hoping for they did that realistic
mode which lets you tweak the settings
and whatnot that does make it on a treat
like that's fun I like hit mode or
something
so Michael Hardy and I actually did like
we were like we like made a campaign out
of it like we made our soldiers and like
picked our classes and you're like
alright we're gonna try to like make
this as realistic and immersive as
possible we like turned off the HUD so
we didn't have all those like markers
showing up and that was a lot of fun
it's something that we've been wanting
to revisit but you know video games
there's a lot of them but it was it was
actually a blast like I'm excited to
return to that and I really hope like
you know making games really hard but I
hope you'd be soft like Kanna
maybe caters to that the old-school
audience at some point because like he
was Splinter Cell is a game that I yeah
I wonder if two more still in chat but
man do I miss those old splinters and
they're always there you know I can play
whatever which I do every now and then
so good yeah it's weird it's like a big
gulp and it seems like there's people
see that that's sort of like late
generation swing we saw two games as a
service everything and you know you know
multiplayer stop everything I have a
multiplayer mode in it like hopefully
we'll yeah I think [ __ ] huge for the
biggest games ever Last of Us flood for
him like all day there's so many games
like that that people love to play over
and over again that retain communities
like maybe not the Last of Us but like
look how like I think what's crazy about
the Miyazaki games is that they they
actually continue to have a community
way after launch
even though mm-hmm not at any being
added to those games and I think when
you have like games that are more
systemic and more
or you know you could peel them apart
more than say a you know a lot of us or
you know uncharged or something then you
get that longevity it's just like a
different type of it I guess I get right
maybe so easily but you know yeah yeah
it's it's not a an original opinion but
I I definitely miss when Ubisoft games
felt a little more different from each
other you know where Splinter Cell felt
different from Ghost Recon which felt
different from rainbow even though like
on surface they all seem the same but
like they all felt so unique in the way
they play it and I yeah I missed when I
saw so much I was I'm really surprised I
haven't done anything with it because
like you know without metal gear now
there's such a gap for like that kind of
game that like yeah tactical espionage
and I will say I'm really excited for
watchdogs 3 with like Clint Hocking back
making games I'm super excited to see
what he's gonna do cuz that guy that guy
did chaos theory and Brian Wright - and
I'm like pretty much stopped after that
and like those are I feel like two of
Ubisoft's best or at least most
interesting games so I'm super excited
to see what happened to watch those
three really curious about how that game
is gonna feel and the current one 100%
true yeah remember in that game felt
contemporary yeah whatever like you know
digital future do we trust Facebook
Briggs that's going on and now it's like
dude that was [ __ ] episode 1 welcome
to season 5 of did you guys play much of
watchdogs - a little it hardly any of it
of the actual game itself but I rocked
up like maybe 15 hours just driving
around
yeah area so I like I like driver and
lake Maris it's what I do
yeah it's it's such a well made version
of the world but like mmm I didn't I
didn't vibe what the you know what they
were going for what the characters and
stuff it just wasn't me yeah yeah my
favorite thing about that game though or
one of my favorite things though was
that there's a mission where
there's like a Martin shkreli type who
buys a bison album and he's the only one
who can listen to it and your yeah your
objective is to like hack into his
accounts and these accounts then release
the album to the world and I was like
alright this is pretty good I like this
ancient history now I know right yeah
yeah sounds about right so yeah I wait
for half of this [ __ ] while I'm not
over but man they should they should
[ __ ] scorch the earth with these
[ __ ] absolutely
oh my god hopefully the next just let
November come and go like oh my god you
know just way he's gonna be like voter
fraud it's just like like I said season
6 & 7 of 2020 you're just gonna be yeah
by a play session man just sit here with
my buddies find some chickens I can't
take that away from me uh speaking of
which mind not speak in which if you'd
like to donate to black lives matter you
can do so at bit ly / GS - BLM or if
you'd like to donate - Cova direct
relief you can do that at bit ly / GS -
co vid and we are reading out the
donations as they come in and thank you
all so much for the support thank you
all so much well last 25 minutes right
so yeah you got a question questions
going to us got some extra bucks you
want to throw towards it do it and of
course we won't be actually will still
have a lot of coverage tomorrow because
there's a bunch of not III but e3 press
conference is happening tomorrow is
really there's the weather there's the
future gaming show yeah there's the PC
show and there's the guerrilla
collective oh yes so there's a good
amount of stuff going on but these
streams happen Monday through Friday
usually around the same time it kind of
changes depending on the guests but stay
tuned keep stopping by share with your
friends share with your family
uh our neighbors they're not there
they're at home don't worry
today knock on the door yeah
please don't ace get on in there I'm
gonna jump over my favorite trick I'm
gonna do it again I love this trick here
it's so stupid
little puppies and what else put the
PlayStation thingamajigger are we are we
hyped I one thing that they didn't
really I guess I don't know how you show
in a press conference but I'm really
excited to see what they plan on doing
with audio because I remember that was a
big thing then mark Cerny was talking
about in the interview I think with
wired last year so I'm super curious to
see what that is going to actually be
like when you people have their hands on
the console once again I don't know how
you show that but yeah it's it's so hard
to show so much of this because like
yeah your mark doesn't show framerate
stuff doesn't show what the high ends
resolution doesn't show like it buntings
YouTube is compressing the hell out of
it just like there's so many barriers to
what that is now that you just kind of
have to go on go on faith in a way you
used to be able to go into a Gamestop
and just look at the console but like I
mean I guess I could do that what might
kill 10 people on the way there gotta
weigh these things up you know the world
you live in did you guys see the thing
where people were like thinking that all
the the Talking Heads in between the
games were were digital renders they
didn't like the lighting the lighting
was really good it just they just had a
really good sight the backlight on them
there's like this furious debate I want
to say in the GameSpot slackers like is
this a person is this a real person was
that a real person
and like we were like waiting at the end
for them to like reveal that they were
all fake but then it didn't happen my
god those are all real people
I felt like if I like one of those like
mismatches that happens when
like you'd record up in a lot more about
no TV days but like you'd record on like
a European framerate and then down to
America where there was something going
on which didn't feel right and then
people were trying to figure out what a
was like maybe all those interviews were
filmed in 30 or something and then maybe
yeah some weird yeah but it wasn't the
yeah they weren't they weren't fake
oh we're probably on longer lenses than
usual because they probably had to do
them and actually I don't know because
they had Angie Smits and a bunch of
those gorilla folks who were obviously
in Amsterdam they didn't gotten a plane
to do that so I'm really curious about
that hmm Norman say what it's on all
those guys it wasn't for those gonna B's
and I should have because John Bart's
was there as well the punchy other guys
from gorilla not to be confused with
kureta collective which is on this
Sunday do you guys remember I think it
was before Metal Gear Solid 5 came out
because she was tweeting images of the
office one in Fox engine and one real
and he was like which one's real
oh yeah he it would be like it would be
like a desk plant or something like that
and it'd be like ones the Fox engine one
isn't what do you think is that I'm just
like I don't know why I thought quite no
it was like pretty tough to turn it
apart but also but it was like I mean
it's an office like I don't know I've
never been to this office like nailed it
on Steam if you want further I think
it's like 20 bucks or something
yeah or you can spend those 20 bucks
donating to their needs just like Justin
Gloup Gloup phenom love you Justin who
donated $25 to black lives matter Thank
You Jessica thank you you've made a
better place
sorry for talking over you John Luke oh
no I all good I suggest I think if I
said just a Maxon I meant Dustin
Justin oh that's better just me in the
place to be
I think the game automatically suck it
sucking me slightly towards these a
little little rampy rampy gents I know I
feel like we've seen those a couple of
times then yeah I think they're I think
they're give me a bit of a bit of help
I got no scratches on this deck that's
usually a sign of like skater
embarrassments if you guys got trucks
sir clean all the trucks are grand a
little but the deck is just the does the
deck and the deck and truck where see
you play now they should add that
that'll be fun yeah a little mesh on it
and it just gets all scratched up and
[ __ ] so now I love snap decks not that
to be great
yeah I think Sony said they filmed them
at their homes some were definitely
using webcams so maybe it was a case
where they like some like kind of posts
a work on it and that kind of gave the
appearance that it looked unnatural and
that's what will happen okay I could see
that like they oh oh I know what they
did maybe what they did is okay this is
no cuz the hair will be too hard okay I
had a I had a crazy idea which is what
they did was that they meshed that onto
a model but that would be way too
ridiculous yeah what they probably did
was they added like depth of fields
maybe artificially and all the lighting
is may be done on a on like a slight
subsurface level there's like an element
of the light and the and the boku maybe
that's that's my guess yeah like Goku
I'm speaking French sure um yeah I
wonder God that'd be crazy if they did I
[ __ ] on webcams I mean they're probably
good right down as well
they do it over zoom which which Tony
Hawk game had like the aggression meter
like if you ate [ __ ] you could like tap
Y as quickly as possible and you'd like
smash your board and kick it to my feels
like it would be a thug it would be a
thug sort of sure Majid knows yes and
that let us know master Paget we're the
last 50 minutes almost folks get those
donations in find me and you're gonna
snap my deck I need I need funds for a
new doctor hell yeah I see I see foggy
bear says thug2 matt says the wait it
was thug - ok so thug - Ardmore thug -
this games are fun there were less my
style than the other ones but they were
so yeah I I think the thing with those
games for me is that I just didn't play
him as much like I played through him
and enjoyed him but I don't think I came
back to him nearly as much although I
did really like underground one at the
time just cuz I was like man it's
telling a story and a skateboarding game
hell yeah but I feel like if I print
yeah
I forget is like Erik or something but I
feel like if I played it again I'd be
like yeah the story's not great I'd
rather just skate board could be wrong
now stratosphere lay good I do it here
maybe not sure if I have enough push
here but let's try it
look Oh almost replace a couple of teeth
there a couple of that cool local games
local Emeryville games get made - we had
a odd Walden habitants announced their
news oh yeah that would that's awesome
really really happy doing that something
well guys sold something and then the
other one is a what's called God gods
gods thing oh is that the gear box
published one the god fall yes I think
so God fall yeah that's also being made
story so sorry yeah I think God world
and have an intern Berkeley that's where
Lauren laning is anyway that's cool yeah
new spider-man new spider-man coming out
I heard it's a not a full game it was
maybe I don't know anymore because they
were like oh it's annex Sony said it was
an expansion but then insomniac said
handle own game but like it's it's maybe
more of a infamous first light or type
thing or like yeah Lost Legacy yeah
attack something like that which I'm
saying yeah I'm not surprised just cuz
like it's spider-man came out like what
end of 2018 like that's not that long so
I'm sort of like what like it's coming
out this year that seems crazy soon for
like a full period so it's the launch
title holiday said 2020 I think yeah
it's totally I think from a production
standpoint you you if you like read the
tea leaves on I you're like how could
that possibly be as big as spider-man
especially spider arms a really long
game
but I think it's just it's like it's
it's like unfortunate because it's
another situation where an
african-american character is getting a
side story I mean it's kind of like I
remember actually being sad about first
lights which is again it's like oh
awesome great you're gonna make a game
with a female protagonist like on a
first-party big it's so anything oh it's
a side story yeah yeah like aren't games
that have black protagonist a female
protagonist that's not the thing but
it's just it's kind of just emblematic
of a wider cultural trend that perhaps
we need to start shaking off like it's a
it's like a shame like I'd love that to
be a full game my my enjoyment but also
just like that seems like the it also
seems like at the end of spider-man
that's what I assumed the next
spider-man would be yeah my sum was it
was gonna be a co-op game and he would
play as both like
Oh baby it so maybe that's what they'll
do in the next one that'll be rad that's
what I'm speculating is they oh you make
this one okay now you learn how to play
miles and he has different powers and
then the third game is your like big
co-op game with both of them
alright better it's Gwen and Myles in
the next one I'd be I would take you I'm
pretty cool have you seen it - the
spider-verse oh I love that movie
absolutely fantastic great I'm not like
a spider-man fan or anything but I
absolutely adored that thing yeah I'm
not like a spider-man person I was the
spider-man fan as a kid like hardcore
spider-man fan like Sam Raimi movies
like the TV show the comics and then
that's the dark area for Hobbit but I
felt I fell off real hard and I was just
like kind of apathetic turned spider-man
for a while like Tom Hollands pretty
good in in yeah but like I'm still sort
of just like I don't know it's kind of
whatever and I think that was the one
like seeing that movie it's I felt like
a like a kid like it gave me the same
feeling as I was when I was like eight
you know super in the forum Enzo's like
I love that movie I gotta finish the
spider or spider-man game on PlayStation
I got very close and other games came
out and had
I'm very good I think by now that's one
of my other favorite interpretations
right I wonder if like coz that game
sold like crazy right like that's isn't
that Playstations like highest selling
exclusive ever or something I wonder if
like a lot of it was like Sony was like
hey if we're gonna launch a console we
should have a spider-man game along with
yeah cuz and like I feel like that's
something you always see with launch
games or it's like a lot of those don't
seem to have a super long development
time or if they do a lot of that
development time is spent like learning
the new tech and whatnot so I wonder if
yeah I mean I don't want to like I don't
I don't want it this is obviously just
me guessing and going on but like I
could see that being a thing too because
most of most of the stuff does have it
that's why you tend to get lots of known
quantities like you'll get x equals two
games it or existed or new versions of
them you got racing games you got like
platforming stuff like this there's a
reason why you don't get much gameplay
innovation on those early launch games
it's because they get the dev kits like
as late as possible probably makes sense
that they'd they'd gopher yeah like so I
like I would rather have this and for
launch than not have us push there is
multiple truths in this and the other
one is that it's a it's sort of a shame
it's not the full thing but hopefully
they'll you know make good on it and
later
it's definitely I'm sure they've they've
heard it loud and clear and hopefully
learned that lesson yeah I bet they knew
as well are getting lost in translation
here too we don't know about like if we
knew what the next spider-man was then
maybe this would get the ear a little
bit better right yeah and we all and
also just yeah I don't think I'm not
sure if there has been actual proper
clarification I want the deal is with oh
yeah let's play it anyway me too very
excited yeah dude great thus Corian that
again do not care about spider-man's
narrative any of that stuff the story in
that game was so brilliant yeah really
good like I said I think it's my
favorite like Peter Parker spider-man
like it's like his I don't know just
something about
acting in the the storytelling like it
just hits really really good like oh you
have to turn with the or to or or TLT
and if you double tap them it does that
but of course I'm like I think like
little you know course corrections a
little bit you know trying to get the
angle right so I double top and then
make spins around into fakie and I'm
like ah [ __ ] stop alright we had 10
minutes left on the stream let's try to
finish strong if you'd like to donate
you can do so at bit dot ly slash games
or GS - black BLM Wow I messed up every
part of that there all the links are in
the chat so you can find those but once
again thank you so much for tuning in
and keep it coming let's finish strong
yeah we're vibin Aires is this is a good
[ __ ]
enjoying the shooting the breeze
absolutely hang on Danny this has been a
lot of fun it's just chatting great
totally there are no way you hit it nice
edit the rail a few times I know alright
yeah it's got no testicle digital Danny
but it's got a it's like joining the
like a eunuch sort of
you gotta you gotta hand the hand the
man when you start what do you guys do
for the rest of your Saturday you got
some more work stuff going on or
Saturday all right Friday Friday
oh god don't scare me like that uh I got
it I'm working on a small little video
about Resident Evil 8 but awesome just
getting that out of the way so I can
enjoy my weekend I'm gonna check out
early because I was working late last
night to get the last of us review up
mm-hmm
Wow yeah good job go check it out Kylie
put it up it was midnight right there I
went up 12:01 yeah that's why I'm sure
blast of his hot takes going around
sweetness yeah I read our review is
really good was uh I skipped a couple of
paragraphs cuz I'm trying to get into
this one it's yeah I'm sorry I'm the mo
I was such a baby when it comes to
splutters like anything we'll just send
my imagination in it might not even be a
spoiler but my brain will think
something's gonna happen man reading so
try not to bother some comic I know
right hopefully on Friday we sort the
reviews up though if you want to check
that out after this stream and also
against what I've dark we had a very
long discussion spoiler free discussion
about it with Khalif Adams from spawn on
me was really good it's definitely make
sure to check that out we had a good
time and neck I said oh what's that
master those are [ __ ] those are like
diamond from buy yeah I thought I was
friends with some of that so many PR
people I'm like that Sony does I believe
he doesn't have a code himself so I was
like I'm not gonna ask him and also like
what people shouldn't send us codes I
don't my own channel of a
of debt stranding but only because it
was just a sicko weirdest game ever and
I just wanted was a was an interesting
one because that's one of the few times
where I think every almost everyone in
the office got a code oh really
interesting yeah that's very rare but
especially for something like everyone
on content I think was was playing yeah
I mean that everyone in there building
bridges for each other yeah that's
actually probably why cuz they I think
they needed to make that mechanic work
it's so funny I go in here I I have been
enjoying the physics though cuz like it
seems like it slightly too exaggerated
on everything and it just works it's
good they really hit their uh hit their
spot without be cuz it's tricky to do
this stuff it's harder than skate but
it's also not stupid and surmountable
you know the mean like you know you
don't get that like real like suck it
onto ledges like you tend to snap to it
you know or like Tony Hawk or you just
know you just hit triangle you snaps or
whatever's next year and but it's also
not like it's not ridiculous either it's
not too finicky like once you're on a
rail it feels like you can stay on a
pretty easily but it also depends like
if I do a 500 or a 50-50 it feels fine
but if you do board slides especially if
you go into a boardslide fakie like a
backside boardslide then you end up like
it's it's it doesn't like that like your
balance gets thrown off and you'll fall
off the board so the board we find it
you don't carry the correct momentum
you'll end up actually spinning see if I
can do it now minutes folks get those
donations hey let's see some donations
I'll make you I'll make you a cool
nickname if you get your donations in
it's the one I might even sing a song of
a
a gray fox that's what games were
playing over the weekend
I might play spider-man again I was
thinking about it I uh I have like one
achievement left which is like the new
game + hard is difficulty and I kind of
want to get it and I feels like a good
time to replay it I'm gonna play me and
my wife have our like Co vids like hobby
has been the Age of Empires to remaster
oh yeah we have played like just like a
LAN party style playing the two of us
against the computer and playing
skirmish modes and NIC and lobbies it's
it's been a bit flaky the past week with
the connectivity we've gotta come to
crashes - which sucks in an AoE game um
but we are it's such a good remaster and
yeah we just sit down here I just make a
little drink and she just like has the
baby monitor there and we once I once
our daughter's asleep we just kind of
sit here and say AoE for like an error
or like three hours or whatever it's so
much fun and the two of us play very
different types of games like um she's
way into a lot of the Ubisoft Far Cry
kind of and she's like completed most of
those games like twice already and and
but she historically loved you don't
have actually behind me Pharaoh it's
like an old PC game she was way into
that and would always play it on em I
got her they did it GOG actually it's
all coming together GOG actually had had
it on their system so I ended up getting
a downloading at noon getting it running
on her Mac as a hack and she was paying
that for a couple of years and then yeah
I was kind of like have you ever played
a tremendous what made me so much
because it's a bit more warlike it's
like between Starcraft and Pharoah Age
of Empires lives and yeah we gave it a
go one night we're just kind of like
[ __ ] let's give it a go and she played
one game I was like oh this is really
fun and we played like can't even tell
you hundred hours be easy at this stage
over the past few months so it's been a
blast and it's it's also like been the
first like a video game that the two of
us have really been able to like have
fun with and like spend a bunch of time
together on like we played Rock Utley
and like Mario Kart stuff but like not
something you can like really like get
good at and have like fun wit so it's
been a blast so I'm probably gonna a
buncha not to speak and maybe one or two
other things
the CNC remaster acts haven't played yet
even though I've been editing a
documentary on her for [ __ ] two weeks
so my jump at the dock yeah what am I
your subject I want to play a bit more
valor in I think I played some last
weekend we actually got like a couple
people from the GameSpot discord
community and with us we did like a full
it kind of felt like a LAN party too cuz
we've had like almost the five beat five
I think yeah ended up with a 4v5 which
was a little uneven but it was fun oh
thing that's awesome
yeah it was fun I think it's like a good
way to play that game too just because I
know it's very intimidating to some
people but I was having fun I think we
got some more donations though I said we
got two more donations for Co vid Direct
Relief $20 from grey fox that says hello
i was like 'hey gray fox and a song
please said want a nickname and a song
name in a song okay great box man it's
already a nickname great inbox grey fox
was a fox socks clocks knocks you can't
knocks gray fox that's more of a slogan
than a nickname who's the next person uh
uh gnar gnar waz I'm gonna butcher this
not narwhal I was I came times that last
name NAR waz
it's just now waz $10 for coven Nomad
great Fox I'm gonna go what I'm gonna go
big balls gray fox that's your nickname
now because we're talking about balls on
this this rampant have my skater here
how would be Oh beautiful no slime like
to fasten to no slide to eat it big
balls gray fox you gotta sing a song
about biggest balls gray fox all right
what am i doing ah
his name is great ox he's got the
biggest balls he doesn't like the
skateboard because it hurts his nuts his
name is grey fox give money to charity
what a cool person I don't even know
it's a male presented person but they
have big balls maybe they're bowling
balls it's up to your interpretation
yeah cool
fantastic tomorrow thankfully help me is
helping me with the pronunciation it's
gnar waz Iqbal it's how I was Iqbal
Iqbal that's how you exhibit thank you
tomorrow
I appreciate that I've been incredibly
white and I don't know how to pronounce
any names we're gonna go in our Wars
stickball because they have sick balls
son theme name is Nawaz he's got sick
balls I'm nice and clean and tries not
to many grinds on rail slides
his name is Nara was he gives to charity
he may be the last person who gave
charity on this dream I don't know is he
I think I think so I think so writ 201
that's about to do it
time to hang up the skateboard go to bed
over here where I live as we're
skateboarders live they come from sewers
alright well that was that was day nine
of GameSpot's play for all charity
stream make sure to tune in next week
for more streams like these we've got
some great stuff lined up chasidy and
Lucy have done and Tamar have done an
excellent job lining up guests we've got
a bunch of awesome stuff planned as well
as make sure to tune in this weekend
because we will be covering a lot of
shows tomorrow in particular and you
won't want to miss that I'm sure there's
gonna be some great announcements and if
you can please make sure to donate all
this stuff goes to really great causes
that could really use the funding so
anything you have helps if not share it
with friends get get the word out
but anyway it's been a blast thank you
so much to Danny for joining us this
one's for you Jake oh did you see the
serie one I really want the serial on
wait if you know she's at the table as
well or know there's an in row at a
nindroid of Serie - what's it look like
it's like Oh actually I think I I think
I might have one here okay it's very
similar it's just yeah give me let's
talk afterwards I'll send it over we get
stuff we got a bunch of stuff from cdeep
Roger
for the noclip studio and I think they
sent over a duplicate of the Serie one
so let's talk okay turn it over to you
all right sounds good thank you to
everyone for donating and thanks to Eric
for sorting it out and more and everyone
for organizing it chastity and always
fun to hang your toe you know III we can
usually get to hang out and see you guys
so in a way we managed to do that here
so awesome whatever spot I'm there yeah
thanks Adam pleasure as ever you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]